[Music]
[Applause]
uh Andy Staples covers college football
for on three Sports he'll be at the Rose
Bowl with Michigan and Alabama and also
the national title game as well Andy
thanks for joining us good morning I'm
curious what's the difference in pay the
going rate for a valuable player in the
transfer portal and then a really
valuable High School recruit
well it it depends and I think the
transfer is more expensive now uh I
think the transfer a transfer
quarterback who's going to make a
difference a transfer defensive tackle
offensive lineman you could be into
seven figures low seven figures I think
only the very top of the high school
quarterback Market reaches that level
other than that it's it's it's lower and
the transfers have become more expensive
than the high school players as they've
gone on because the coaches realize okay
these guys are making business decisions
they're here they want to get to the NFL
the high school players are more of a
crapshoot would you rather win national
Signing Day or transfer portal
day at this point I still rather win
national Signing Day and I'll tell I'll
tell you why I don't think you can get
the quality big guys unless you get them
out of high school we had Kirby Smart on
my show yesterday and he just keeps
winning at Georgia because when you look
at like he brought in double digigit
offensive and defensive linemen out of
the high school ranks these these guys
are monsters they're like 6'7 370 PBS 67
345 like I don't even know how humans
have gotten this big but these are are
monsters who can move and you know what
they may not all start at Georgia some
of them may transfer out and go play
somewhere else but the ones who succeed
who beat out all the other ones that
they already have and start at Georgia
are probably going to be better than
everybody else's and that's why they
keep winning we brought this up
yesterday just sort of speculation or
maybe the possibility hypothetical could
you see Kirby Smart wanting to coach the
Atlanta
Falcons I see I I was getting New
England Patriots because he comes off
the Sabin tree which is effectively the
bellich tree uh I I don't see it he you
know like he's a South Georgia guy but I
think he's good where he is he knows
that one of the things he's really good
at is recruiting is evaluating doing
what he did yesterday getting that
number one signing class I I've never
gotten the sense that he has that itch
to coach in the NFL I I think he likes
where he's at but the When you mention
it I I kind of like that I I I think
Patriots more than falcons okay though I
cannot imagine the culture shock of him
trying to live in New England versus
living in Georgia give me the programs
you think overachieved
yesterday well I think Oregon did really
well uh Dan Lanning continues to to
build that roster in in a really good
way for the Big 10 and I it started with
Mario chrisal when he was the head coach
there where he got them better on the
lines of scrimmage because Oregon was
always getting good skill Talent going
back to to Mike bot and Chip Kelly but
they really needed to get better in the
trenches and I think Mario left but Dan
lenning continued that uh they got an
edge rusher out of out of Tucson uh his
last name is rushing so it's is a
perfect perfectly aptly named but
they've done really well with that but
they also have mixed in the transfer
portal as well CU that's that's one of
those where they haven't had a a
readymade roster each year where they've
had that many great classes stacked on
top of each other so they do a good job
of mixing them both up it Florida State
lost their biggest recruit to Georgia
but if you look at it they actually have
a deeper more quality class than they've
had in about 10 years and add something
when Jimbo Fischer left it was kind of a
mess and I was wondering how long it was
going to take to get back to signing
classes like that well Mike norel did a
lot of good work in the transfer portal
obviously has had great success the last
two years and now the high school
players are saying you know what I I see
the vision here and I want to jump on so
it it was kind of negative for them
yesterday because of the one guy they
lost to Georgia which was a safety from
Buford Georgia but I think overall
they're they're on an upward trajectory
let me go back to Oregon how much of
their Collective is just Nike
money I think a lot of it but you know
however it works and the thing about
Nike that that has to they have to be a
little careful with is Nike does
business with all these schools so you
can't just build up Oregon that's that's
why I keep telling people and
everybody's like oh Oregon would just
buy all the best players well you know
who that would piss off Georgia Alabama
Michigan Ohio State who also do business
with
Nike
we're talking to Andy Staples he covers
college football for Onre Sports Arch
Manning situation at Texas and how much
of that is dependent on Quinn yers
coming
back well I I think he's going to be the
backup there and and I don't I never got
the sense from Arch that it was a play
immediately kind of thing or even a play
within the first two years as the
starter kind of thing he's the backup
right now if Quinn ERS decides to stay I
think the plan would be for Arch to take
over and the other thing is Quinn ERS
has been knocked out each of the last
two seasons for multiple games so if
you're backing up Quinn ERS there's a
very good chance you're going to be the
starter at some point and Dan I I know
you've met a lot of quarterbacks you
know how they think once I'm in there I
ain't giving it back the ncia and Jim
Harbaugh where are
we so this is essentially the Jim
Trestle case from 12 Years A ago the
only thing that's changed is everything
else around it because basically what
they got Harbaugh on is not telling the
truth to the NCAA uh they call this
cheeseburger gate at Michigan and
basically what happened was during covid
there there were some recruits one of
them was committed to Michigan already
they drove to campus on their own dime
just wanted to look around but schools
were not supposed to have any recruits
on campus whether they were unofficial
visits offic didn't matter you weren't
supposed to have anybody at that time
and so Jim Harbaugh goes and meets them
at a restaurant and when the NCAA asks
about this he says I don't recall they
hand him a receipt do you recall now I
don't recall and so they're saying he
was providing misleading information to
the investigators which is exactly what
they got Jim Trestle for the difference
is in 2011 Ohio State forced Jim Trestle
out because people were still like oh my
goodness he committed an NCAA violation
and now we're like who cares Michigan's
like Michigan's thing is we're more
worried about Jim Harbaugh going to the
NFL we would like to keep him but here's
the interesting part remember they were
going to do a negotiated basically a
plea bargain where Jim Harbaugh was
going to be suspended for four games
that got rejected by the committee on
infractions Michigan then self-imposed
three games so we already know they want
more than four games as a suspension and
I don't think they're going to tack on
those three that he got for the the
Conor stallion signal stealing stuff at
the end of the season I don't think that
gets tacked on because that's a separate
NCAA investigation so yeah I I think
there's more suspension coming from the
NCAA once all this gets settled but
Michigan's not going to cave and fire
him I don't think the way Ohio State
caved and Fir J Trestle okay but is
Harbaugh now more likely to try to go to
the NFL again than sit around and wait
for these you know whatever sanctions
are going to happen or penalties I think
he's going to try to go to the NFL
anyway Dan because I I think he's wanted
to I I think there's still an itch there
and remember he was a really good NL
what is holding this up with
Harbaugh wanting to hire him but he's a
proven Talent why would you take Arthur
Smith when you could have Jim Harbaugh
why would you take Matt rule when you
could have Jim Harbaugh see ask Ziggy
wil he could have had I know Jim
Harbaugh well I do like that
coach yeah I do too I think Kevin
connell's a great coach yes yes I
understand that but there are a lot of
other coaches that are
pedestrian well and that's the thing I
think there could be jobs where Jim
Harbaugh would be a good fit like if if
Chicago fires Matt Eber flu I mean you
you put Jim Harbaugh there with a number
one draft pick quarterback assuming I
know the Panthers won the other day so I
don't know the Bears pick is still
number one for now if the Panthers go on
a winning streak we'll see about that
but you got the Bears you got the
Chargers job is open you want you want
Jim Harbaugh working with Justin Herbert
yeah that'd probably be a pretty good
thing so I think how about this
you need to think about it the Chargers
you can have Bill bich or Jim
Harbaugh o
o I'm worried about belich belich non
Brady is a scary thought and and the
question with I have with belich and
actually it's a question I'd ask with
Harbaugh too because he's coming from
the college ranks where you have full
Personnel control bellich the GM worries
me more than belich the coach so I'm not
sure how I because I think both those
guys are going to want
very tight Personnel
control I think I think I might go
Harbaugh to work just to work with
Herbert there was a report yesterday
that uh there's still NFL chatter about
Lincoln
Riley can you why
well I don't know I I mean I don't know
if he had a good or bad day yesterday
but I I don't know if if Lincoln Riley
it he was pretty desirable you know when
the season started I would think for NFL
teams but you think that's cooled off I
think he's still desirable as an
offensive tactician you know what
happened yesterday is really Irrelevant
in terms of of the NFL because whether
Lincoln riy can recruit or not doesn't
matter in the NFL it's how does he
scheme up that offense but also how
willing is he to work with his defensive
coordinator to put a good defense on the
field I think that is the bigger concern
whether it's the NFL or college football
Lincoln Riley has yet to show that he
can he can have a program that has a
good defense that he can practice in a
way that allows the defense to also get
what its needs that he can hire a
defensive coordinator who can put a
dominant defense on the field those are
all things that Lincoln Riley needs to
prove and those would be issues in the
NFL and they are issues at USC right now
great to talk to Andy uh happy holidays
to you and the family and thanks for
joining us as always thank you Dan
that's Andy Staples at on three Forge